next franklin d roosevelt's 1933
presidential inauguration this
inauguration was the last one held in
march
the 20th amendment fixed inauguration
day in january this is about 20 minutes
[Music]
so
[Music]
you franklin teleno roosevelt
do solemnly swear
[Music]
that you will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states
and will
to the best of your ability
preserve
protect
and defend
the constitution of the united states so
help you god
i franklin delano roosevelt
who solemnly swear
that i will faithfully execute the
office of president of the united states
and will to the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states so
help me god
[Music]
mr president justice
my friends
this is a day of national consecration
and i am certain that on this day my
fellow americans
expect that on my induction into the
presidency
i will address them with a candor
and a decision
which the present situation of our
people impel
this is preeminently the time
to speak the truth
the whole truth frankly
and boldly
nor need we shrink
from honestly facing conditions in our
country today
this great nation will endure
as it has endured
will revive and will prosper
so first of all
let me assert my firm belief
that the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself
nameless unreasoning unjustified terror
which paralyzes needed effort
to convert retreat
into advance
in every dark hour of our national life
a leadership of frankness and a figure
has met with that understanding and
support of the people themselves
which is essential to victory
and i am convinced that you will again
give that support to leadership in these
critical days
in such a spirit on my part and on yours
we face our common difficulties
they concern thank god
only material thing
values have shrunk to fantastic levels
taxes have risen
our ability to pay has fallen
government of all kinds is faced by
serious curtailment of income
the means of exchange are frozen in the
currents of trade
the withered leaves of industrial
enterprise lie on every side
farmers find no markets for their
produce
and the savings of many years and
thousands of families are gone
more important
a host of unemployed citizens
face the grim problem of existence
and an equally great number toil with
little return
only a foolish optimist can deny the
dark realities of the moment
and yet our distress comes from no
failure of substance
we are stricken by no plague of locusts
compared with the perils which our
forefathers conquered
because they believed and were not
afraid
we have still much to be thankful for
nature still offers a bounty and human
efforts have multiplied it
plenty is at our doorstep
but a generous use of it languishes in
the very sight of the supply
primarily
this is because the rulers of the
exchange
of mankind's good
have failed through their own
stubbornness
and their own incompetence
have admitted their failure and have
abdicated
practices
of the unscrupulous money changers
stand indicted in the court of public
opinion
rejected by the hearts and minds of
men true they have tried
but their efforts have been cast in the
pattern of an outworn tradition
faced by failure of credit
they have proposed only the lending of
more money
by which to induce our people to follow
their false leadership
they have resorted to exhortation
pleading carefully for restored
confidence
they only know the rules of a generation
of self-seekers
they have no vision
and when there is no vision the people
perish
yes the money changers have fled
from their high seats in the temple of
our civilization
we may now restore that temple to the
ancient truth
the measure of that restoration lies in
the extent to which we apply social
values
more noble than mere monetary profit
happiness lies not in the mere
possession of money it lies in the joy
of achievement in the thrill of creative
effort
the joy the moral stimulation of work
no longer must be forgotten in the mad
chaste of evanescence prophets
these dark days my friends will be worth
all late foster if they teach us that
our true destiny
is not to be ministered unto
but to minister to ourselves to our
fellow man
recognition
of that falsity of material wealth as
the standard of success
goes hand in hand with the abandonment
of the false belief that public office
and high political positions
are to be valued only by the standards
of pride of place and personal profits
and there must be an end
to a conduct in banking and in business
which too often has given to a sacred
trust the likeness of callous and
selfish wrongdoing
small wonder
that confidence languishes
for it thrives only on honesty
on honor
on the sacredness of obligations
on faithful protection
and on unselfish performance without
them it cannot live
restoration calls however
not for changes in ethics alone
this nation is asking for action
and action now
our greatest primary task is to put
people to work
this is no unsolvable problem if we face
it wisely and courageously
it can be accomplished in part
by direct recruiting by the government
itself
treating the task as we would treat the
emergency of a war
but at the same time through this
employment
accomplishing great greatly needed
projects to stimulate and reorganize the
use of our great natural resources
hand in hand with that
we must frankly recognize the over
balance of population in our industrial
centers
and by engaging on a national scale
in a redistribution
endeavor to provide a better use of the
land for those best fitted for the land
yes the task can be helped by definite
efforts to raise the values of
agricultural products
and with this the power to purchase the
output of our cities
it can be helped
by preventing realistically
the tragedy is the growing loss through
foreclosure
of our small homes and our farms
it can be helped by insistence
that the federal
the state
and the local governments act forth with
on the demand that their cost be
drastically reduced
it can be helped
by the unifying of relief activities
which today are often scattered
uneconomical unequal
it can be helped by national planning
for
and supervision of all forms of
transportation
and of communications and other
utilities that have a definitely public
character
there are many ways in which it can be
helped
but it can never be helped by merely
talking about it
we must act we must act quickly
and finally in our progress towards a
resumption of work
we require two safeguards
against a return of the evils of the old
order
there must be a strict supervision
of all banking and credits and
investments
there must be an end to speculation with
other people's money
[Applause]
and there must be provision for an
adequate but sound currency
these my friends are the lines of attack
i shall presently urge upon a new
congress
in special session
detailed measures for their fulfillment
and
i shall seek the immediate assistance of
the 48 states
[Applause]
through this program of action
we address ourselves to putting our own
national house in order
and making income balance outgo
our international trade relations
though vastly important
are in point of time
and necessity
secondary to the establishment of a
sound national economy
[Music]
i favor
as a practical policy the pudding
are first things first
i shall spare no effort
to restore world trade by international
economic readjustment
but the emergency at home
cannot wait on that accomplishment
the basic force that guides these
specific means of national recovery
is not nationally narrowly nationalistic
it is the insistence
as a first consideration
upon the interdependence of the various
elements in and part of the united
states of america
a recognition of the old and prominently
important manifestation
of the american spirit of the pioneer
it is the way to recovery
it is the immediate way
it is the strongest assurance that
recovery will endure
in the field of world policy
i would dedicate this nation
to the policy
of the good
neighbor
the neighbor who resolutely respects
himself
and because he does so
respects the rights of others
the neighbor who respects his
obligations
and respects the sanctity of his
agreements
in and with a world of neighbors
if i read the temple of our people
correctly
we now realize as we have never realized
before
our interdependence on each other
that we cannot merely take
but we must give
as well
but if we are to go forward
we must move as a trained and loyal army
willing to sacrifice
for the good of a common discipline
because without such discipline
no progress can be made
no leadership becomes effective
we are i know ready and willing
to submit our lives and our property
to such discipline
because it makes possible a leadership
which aims at the larger good
this
i propose to offer
pledging that the larger purposes will
bind upon us
bind upon us all
as a sacred obligation
with a unity of duty hitherto evoked
only in times of armed strife
with this pledge taken
i assume unhesitatingly the leadership
of this great army of our people
dedicated to a disciplined attack
upon our common problems
action in this image
action to this end
is feasible
under the form of government which we
have inherited from our ancestors
our constitution is so simple
so practical
that it is possible always to meet
extraordinary needs
by changes in emphasis and arrangement
without loss of essential form
that is why
our constitutional system has proved
itself
the most superbly enduring political
mechanism
the modern world has ever seen
it has met every stress a vast expansion
of territory
of foreign wars
of bitter internal strife
of world relations
and it is to be hoped
that the normal balance of executive and
legislative authority
may be fully equal
fully adequate
to meet the unprecedented task before us
but it may be
that an unprecedented demand
and need for undelayed action
may call
for temporary departure from that normal
balance of public procedure
i am prepared
under my constitutional duty
to recommend the measures that a
stricken nation in the midst of the
stricken world
may require
these measures
or such other measures
as the congress may build
out of its experience and wisdom
i shall seek within my constitutional
authority to bring to speedy adoption
but
in the event that the congress shall
fail to take one of these two courses
in the event that the national emergency
is still critical
i shall not evade the clear course of
duty
that will then confront me
i shall ask the congress for the one
remaining instrument to meet the crisis
fraud
executive power
to wage a war against the emergency
as great
as the power that would be given to me
if we were in fact invaded by a foreign
fall
for the trust proposed in me
i will return the courage and the
devotion that best fits the time i can't
do no less
we face the arduous days that lie before
us
in the warm courage
of national unity
[Music]
with the clear consciousness
of seeking old and precious moral values
with the clean satisfaction that comes
from the stern performance of duty by
old and young alike
we aim at the assurance of a rounded
a permanent
national life
we do not distrust
this the future
of essential democracy
the people of the united states
have not failed
in their need they have registered a
mandate
that they want
direct
vigorous action
they have asked for discipline
and direction under leadership
they have made me the present instrument
of their wishes
in the spirit of the gift
i take it
[Music]
in this dedication of a
nation we humbly ask
the blessing of god
may he protect
each and every one of us
may he guide
me in the days
[Music]
you're watching american history tv on
seaspen 3. coming up next is american
artifact where and where elsewhere might
be
during franklin d roosevelt's presidency
he delivered a number of radio
broadcasts which became known as
fireside chats
president roosevelt used these fireside
chats to inform and build public support
for his administration's efforts during
the great depression world war ii and
the enactment of new deal policies
next president roosevelt's first
fireside chat from march 12
thirty three
this address was titled the banking
crisis
ladies and gentlemen
the president of the united states
my friends
i want to talk for a few minutes with
the people of the united states about
banking
to talk with the comparatively few who
understand the mechanics of banking but
more particularly with the overwhelming
majority of you who use banks for the
making of deposits in the drawing of
checks
i want to tell you what has been done in
the last few days
and why it was done and what the next
steps are going to be
i recognize that the many proclamations
from state capitals and from washington
the legislation the treasury regulations
and so forth
couched for the most part in banking and
legal terms
ought to be explained for the benefit of
the average citizen
i owe this in particular
because of the fortitude and the good
temper which everybody has with which
everybody has accepted the inconvenience
and the hardships of the banking holiday
and i know that when you understand what
we in washington have been about
i shall continue to have your
cooperation as fully as i have had your
sympathy and your health during the past
week
first of all let me state the simple
fact
that when you deposit money in a bank
the bank does not put the money into a
safe deposit vault
it invests your money in many different
forms of credit
in bonds and commercial paper and
mortgages and in many other kinds of
loans
in other words the bank puts your money
to work to keep the wheels of industry
and of agriculture turning around
a comparatively small part of the money
that you put into the bank is kept in
currency
an amount which in normal times is fully
sufficient to cover the cash needs of
the average citizen
in other words the total amount of all
the currency in the country
is only a comparatively small proportion
of the total deposits in all the banks
of the country
what then happened during the last few
days of february in the first few days
of march
because of undermined confidence on the
part of the public
there was a general rush by a large
portion of our population
to turn bank deposits into currency or
gold
a rush so great that the soundest banks
couldn't get enough currency to meet the
demand
the reason for this was
that on the spur of the moment it was of
course impossible to sell perfectly
sound assets of a bank
and convert them into cash
except at panic prices far below their
real value
by the afternoon of march third
a week ago last friday scarcely a bank
in the country was open to do business
proclamations closing them in whole are
in part
had been issued by the governors in
almost all of the states
it was then that i issued the
proclamation
providing for the national bank holiday
and this was the first step in the
government's reconstruction of our
financial and economic fabric
the second step
last thursday
was the legislation promptly and
patriotically passed by the congress
confirming my proclamation and
broadening my powers
so that it became possible in view of
the requirement of time
to extend the holiday and lift the ban
of that holiday gradually in the days to
come
this law also gave authority to develop
a program of rehabilitation of our
banking facilities
and i want to tell our citizens in every
part of the nation
that the national congress republicans
and democrats alike
showed by this action a devotion to
public welfare
and a realization of the emergency and
the necessity for speed
that it is difficult to match in all our
history
the third stage has been the series of
regulations
permitting the banks to continue their
functions to take care of the
distribution of food and household
necessities and the payment of payroll
this bank holiday while resulting in
many cases in great inconvenience
is affording us the opportunity to
supply the currency necessary to meet
the situation
remember that no sound bank is a dollar
worth off
than it was when it closed its doors
last week
neither is any bank which may turn out
not to be
in a position for immediate opening
the new law allows the 12 federal
reserve bank
to issue additional currency on good
assets
and thus the banks that reopen will be
able to meet every legitimate call
the new currency is being sent out by
the bureau of engraving and printing in
large volume to every part of the
country
it is sound currency because it is
backed by actual good asset
another question that you will ask is
this
why are all the banks not to be reopened
at the same time
the answer is simple and i know you will
understand it
your government does not intend that the
history of the past few years shall be
repeated
we do not want and will not have another
epidemic of bank failures
as a result we start tomorrow monday
with the opening of banks in the 12
federal reserve bank cities
those banks which on first examination
by the treasury
have already been found to be all right
that will be followed on tuesday
by the resumption of all other functions
by banks already found to be found in
cities where there are recognized
clearinghouses
that means about 250 cities of the
united states
in other words we're moving as fast as
the mechanics of the situation will
allow
on wednesday
and succeeding days
banks in smaller places all through the
country will resume business
subject of course to the government's
physical ability to complete its survey
it is necessary that the reopening of
banks be extended
over a period in order to permit the
banks to make applications for the
necessary loans
to obtain currency
needed to meet their requirements
and to enable the government to make
common sense checkups
please let me make it clear to you that
if your bank does not open the first day
you are by no means justified in
believing that it will not open
a bank that opens on one of the
subsequent days
is in exactly the same status as the
bank that opens tomorrow
i know that many people are worrying
about state banks that are not members
of the federal reserve system
there is no occasion for that worry
these banks can and will receive
assistance
from member banks and from the
reconstruction finance corporation
and of course they are under the
immediate control of the state banking
authorities
these state banks are following the same
costs as the national banks
except that they get their licenses to
resume business from the state authority
and these authorities have been asked by
the secretary of the treasury to permit
their good banks to open up on the same
schedule as the national banks
and so i am confident that the state
banking department will be as careful as
the national government in the policy
relating to the opening of banks and
will follow the same broad theory
it is possible that when the banks
resume
a very few people
who have not recovered from their fear
may again begin withdrawals
let me make it clear to you that the
banks will take care of all needs
except of course the hysterical demands
of orders
and it is my belief that hoarding during
the past week has become an exceedingly
unfashionable pastime in every part of
our nation
it needs no profit to tell you that when
the people find that they can get their
money
that they can get it when they want it
for all legitimate purposes
the phantom of fear will soon be laid
people will again be glad to have their
money where it will be safely taken care
of
and where they can use it conveniently
at any time
i can assure you my friends
that it is safer to keep your money in a
reopened bank
than it is to keep it under the mattress
the success of our whole national
program depends of course on the
cooperation of the public
on its intelligent support and its use
of a reliable system
remember that the essential
accomplishment of the new legislation
is that it makes it possible for banks
more readily to convert their assets
into cash than was the case before
more liberal provision has been made for
banks to borrow on these assets at the
reserve banks
and more liberal provision has also been
made for issuing currency on the
security of these good assets
this currency is not fiat currency
it is issued only on adequate security
and every good bank has an abundance of
such security
one more point before i close
there will be of course some banks
unable to reopen without being
reorganized
the new law allows the government to
assist in making these reorganizations
quickly and effectively
and even allows the government to
subscribe to at least a part
of any new capital that may be required
i hope you can see my friends from this
essential recital
of what your government is doing
for uh is doing
that there is nothing complex nothing
radical in the process we have had a bad
banking situation some of our bankers
had shown themselves either incompetent
or dishonest in their handling of the
people's funds
they had used the money entrusted to
them in speculations and unwise loans
this was of course not true in the vast
majority of our banks
but it was true in enough of them
to shock the people of the united states
for a time
into a sense of insecurity
and to put them into a frame of mind
where they did not differentiate
but seemed to assume that the acts of a
comparative few had painted them all
and so it became the government's job to
straighten out this situation and to do
it as quickly as possible and that job
is being performed
i do not promise you that every bank
will be reopened
or that individual losses will not be
suffered
but
there will be no losses that possibly
could be avoided
and there would have been more and
greater losses had we continued to drift
i can even promise you promise you
salvation
for some at least of the solely press
banks we shall be engaged not merely in
reopening sound banks but in the
creation of more sound banks through
reorganization
it has been wonderful to me to catch the
note of confidence from all over the
country i can never be sufficiently
grateful to the people for the loyal
support that they have given me in their
acceptance of the judgment that has
dictated our course
even though all our processes may not
have seemed clear to them after all
there is an element in the readjustment
of our financial system
more important than currency more
important than gold
and that is the confidence of the people
courage are the themselves of success in
carrying out our plan
you people must have faith
you must not be stampeded by rumors or
guesses
let us unite in banishing fear
we have provided the machinery to
restore our financial system
and it is up to you to support and make
it work
it is your problem my friend
your problem no less than it is mine
together we cannot fail
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states has spoken to you from
the white house in washington dc
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states has spoken to you from
the white house in washington dc
our look at franklin d roosevelt
continues with the universal newsreel
documentary chronicling the former
president's early political career
this footage which lasts about 10
minutes is being shown courtesy of the
fdr library in hyde park new york
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
war work done with the year 1920 finds
franklin d roosevelt at the threshold of
a new career he began to take a
prominent place in councils of his party
his keen-minded and progressive thoughts
were eagerly sought on state national
affair
[Music]
when the democrats gathered to san
francisco in july 1920 for their
national convention roosevelt's name was
on many tongues it was inevitable that
he should be nominated for vice
president to run the james m cox
enthusiastically he stumped the country
preaching the ideals of woodrow wilson
and rallying the party to the support of
the ticket wherever he spoke his vibrant
personality and flashing smile made new
friends there was a ring of sincerity in
his voice that the people liked which
they never forgotten
loyally and energetically fought the
stern battle for his chief and for the
party with james m cox he looked on with
kindling eyes while san francisco turned
out a great parade in their honor these
were stirring hours in the life of our
president or he was getting his first
lessons in the art of national campaign
he loved the gay clamor of the political
battle as he loves it now he responds to
every stirring phase of the exciting
moving panorama of political life these
marching people were not merely voters
to franklin roosevelt they were human
beings and to their greeting he
responded with his gay and gallant
humanity
but his thoughts were back home in
beautiful hyde park with mrs roosevelt
and their four children and very little
folks they were in those days with his
favorite dog his thoughts went back to
the wife defend his boyhood sweetheart
and always his loyal help
but the campaigning had to go on even
though he felt the cause was lost in
speech after speech with the
extraordinary energy which is even now
the amazement of the nation he sought to
rally to discourage democracy
[Music]
wherever he appeared his warm
personality and friends [ __ ] the crowd
people surged about him and when the
campaign came to its close there was the
same eager desire on the part of the
public to get a close-up of this new
young champion of democratic principles
this young man in politics who had
proved himself by good works and then it
was back home in ernest to be greeted at
his door by his adoring mother to speak
to old friends and neighbors in simple
friendly words of breeding and welcome
[Music]
and to shake hands with folks who came
from miles around to greet neighbor
frank
then came an interval of political quiet
spent with mrs roosevelt and with their
four youngsters
and then the great political battle of
1924
alfred e smith and john w davis he stood
out as a leader
there never was a political convention
to match the democratic national
gathering of 1924 in new york for drama
and color and bitterness mcadoo against
al smith day after day of fruitless
pelleting terrific storms of passion
shaking the delegates and convulsing the
thousands and health
the high note of all
franklin d roosevelt's presentation of
the name of alfred e smith the deathless
praise
the happy warrior
[Music]
the democratic convention of houston in
the lone star state and once more
franklin d roosevelt took the stage to
praise as only he could do
the man for whom he has always had such
affection and respect naming him again
the happy warrior his friend alfred
smith the governor of new york
al smith who will always have his own
place in the hearts of the american
people
but events were moving fast al smith's
candidate for president in 1928 wanted a
good man to run for governor of new york
he persuaded franklin roosevelt to make
the race and although mr smith lost the
state by a narrow vote franklin
roosevelt was elected to his first term
as governor and we see him in his new
high office for the first time and as he
participates with mrs lehmann at the
inaugural ball at that very moment an
even greater honor was looming in the
near distance but he himself engrossed
by his duties as governor of the empire
state was content to do the work in hand
occasionally he took time off to attend
public gatherings such as the state fair
at syracuse driving there with his
mother mrs sarah delano roosevelt
and in his democratic fashion he took
his lunch in the outdoor restaurant with
an appetite sharpened by his holiday
away from the rigors of auckland
[Music]
his relaxation and exercise was swimming
ben's now a swimming pool was installed
in an old greenhouse attached to the
executive mansion there the governor
would spend as much time as he could
take his official duties and helpful
recreation and having a grand time
skylarking in the walkers today by the
way he's one of the most powerful
swimmers in the country fuel can match
him with backstroke and leg drive and
it's heartening to know that a fine
swimming pool is now being installed for
him in the basement of the white house
he can continue to get the exercise he
needs to enable him to face his great
tasks
[Music]
but to go back to his rule in new york
there were tents trying days the famous
seabury inquiry was probing the
government of the city samuel c berry
whom we see arriving at the county
courthouse in new york was getting
closer to the mayor of the city jimmy
walker jimmy walker slim smiling
sprightly that we see following judge
seaberry into the courthouse
and it became governor roosevelt's stern
duty eventually to try mayor walker on
the charges seaberry submitted
[Music]
a variety of official duties constantly
made demands on his energy personally he
presided in 1931 at the dedication of
the great washington bridge over the
hudson
in the presence of a great crowd on this
magnificent bridge governor roosevelt
cut the tape which opened the bridge to
traffic between new york and new jersey
and then came the even more tempestuous
months in 1932 when the bonus
expeditionary army invaded washington
the curious situation because the
country had a friendly and sympathetic
feeling for the veterans but when their
masked forces settled down to stay until
congress gave them the cash bonus
the government finally came to the
decision that it had to take strong
measures
sad pathetic episode in our current
history
but the assembling of the democratic
convention in 1932 in chicago drove
almost all other topics out of the minds
of the people already franklin d
roosevelt was the favorite for the
nomination his leading opponent by a
strange travesty of fortune was none
other than his old friend alfred smith
the keynote was sounded by senator
barclay of kentucky
[Music]
in order therefore
to obtain
the present will of the american people
on this subject of universal controversy
this convention
should in the platform here to be
adopted
recommend the passage
by congress
of a resolution
repealing the 18th amendment to the
constitution
but this question of prohibition had
adherence on both sides and meantime the
drives were meeting in convention and
just as vigorously upholding the noble
experiment
repeal swept the democratic convention
but the presidency was the real fight
and the break came when william gibbs
mcadoo went to the speaker's stand
when any man comes into this convention
with 700
worse in it he's entitled to the
nomination
franklin d roosevelt
having received more than two-thirds
of all the delegates voting i proclaim
him the nominee of this convention for
president of the united states
upon word of his nomination governor
roosevelt broke all precedence the way
he has by flying to chicago the country
was thrilled to this news
[Music]
there was a general sigh of relief when
word came that the roosevelt plane after
fighting through a storm and landed
safely in chicago and in a little while
the people heard the roar of chairs that
greeted him in the convention hall and
his own familiar voice and thanks to the
delegates
you have nominated me
and i know it
and i am here to thank you for the honor
let it also be symbolic
that in so doing
i broke tradition i say to you now
that from this date on
the 18th amendment is doomed
i pledge myself
to a new deal for the american people
and then the happy release from politics
and official worries back to his first
love to see off with his tall sons on a
cruise up the new england coast in a 22
foot yaw chief cook and bottle washer as
well as admiral out into the warm summer
sunshine and the health giving ocean
breezes a prisoner of state no longer
but free and carefree just the citizen
on vacation
and then as a man must back to work in
official responsibilities but relieved
and refreshed by his swimming pool and
the good funny has it swimming with his
daughter mrs dahl and his little
grandchild only a few weeks more now
before the hard drive of the
presidential campaign but he is fit and
ready ready to fight for the presidency
our look at franklin d roosevelt
continues with a visit to his
presidential library in hyde park new
york
in 1994 we traveled to the site aboard
the c-span school bus for a tour of the
facility with then director vern newton
it runs about a half hour
yes this is a peaceful countryside
and it seems appropriate
first lady and their influence on the
presidency from martha washington to
michelle obama sundays at 8 pm eastern
on american history tv on c-span 3.
in 1935 franklin d roosevelt put his
signature on the social security act
[Music]
this social security measure
gives at least some protection
to 30 millions of our citizens
who will reap direct benefits through
unemployment compensation
through old age pensions
and through increased services for the
protection of children
and the prevention of ill health
then 15 years later congress passed a
new social security law a law designed
to meet today's needs signed by
president truman in 1950 this act gives
social security a new meaning for you
and so today this is the portrait of the
future a picture which social security
helped make possible
under the social security act most
american families are now able to ensure
for themselves an income that is
guaranteed for life it's an income
provided not by charity or relief but by
federal old age and survivors insurance
insurance that is bought and paid for
[Music]
i am happy to speak to you from my home
on a sabbath day that has been observed
in so many of your home communities as
brotherhood day
the national conference of jews and
christians
has set aside a day on which we can meet
not primarily as protestants or
catholics or jews
but as believing americans
a day on which we can dedicate ourselves
not to the things that divide
but to the things which unite us
i hope that we have begun to see how
many and how important
are the things on which we are
united
now of all times we require that kind of
thinking
there are honest differences of
religious belief
among the citizens of your town
as there are among the citizens of mine
it is a part of the spirit of
brotherhood day
as it is a part of our american heritage
to respect
those differences
and it is well for us to remember that
this america of ours
is the product of no single creed or
race or class men and women your fathers
and mine
came here from the far corners of the
earth
with beliefs that varied widely
and yet
each of them in his own way
laid his own special gift upon our
national altar
to enrich our national life
from the gift that each has given
all have gained
this is no time to make capital
out of religious
differences
however honest
it is a time rather to make capital
out of religious understanding
we who have faith
cannot afford to fall out among
ourselves
the very state of the world
is a summons to us
to stand together
for as i see it
the chief religious issue is not between
our various beliefs
it is between belief and unbelief
it is not your specific faith or mind
that is being called into question
but rather all faith
religion in wide areas in different
parts of the earth is being confronted
with irreligion our faiths are being
challenged
it is because of that threat that you
and i must reach across the lines
between our creeds
must clasp hands and make common cause
to make common cause we'll do credit
to the best of our religious tradition
and it will do credit also to the best
of our american tradition
the spiritual resources of our forebears
have brought us a long way towards the
goal
which has been set before the nation at
its very founding
and yet i do not look upon these united
states as a finished product
we are still in the making
the vision of the early days still
requires the same qualities of faith
faith in god and man for its fulfillment
no greater thing could come to our land
today
than a revival of the spirit of religion
a revival that could sweep through the
homes of the nation
and stir the hopes
and the hearts of men and women of all
faiths
to a reassertion of their belief in god
and their dedication to his will
for themselves and for their world
i doubt if there is any problem social
political or economic
that would not melt away
before the fire of such a spiritual
undertaking
i know of no better way to kindle such a
fire
then through the fellowship
that an occasion like this makes
possible
for brotherhood day after all
is an experiment in understanding
a venture
enabling us
i like to think of our country
as one home in which the interests of
each member
are bound up with the happiness of all
we ought to know by now
that the welfare of your family or of
mine
cannot be bought at the sacrifice of our
neighbor's family
that our well-being depends in the long
run
upon the well-being of our neighbors
the good neighbor idea
ideal
as we are trying to practice it in
international relationships
needs to be put into practice
in our community relationships
when it is we may discover that the road
to understanding and fellowship
is also the road to spiritual awakening
at our neighbor's fireside
we may find new fuel
for the fires of faith at our own hearth
sides
it would be a fitting thing for an
organization
such as the national conference of jews
and christians
to undertake this kind of project in
navalness
i should like to see associations of
good neighbors
in every town and city
and every rural community
throughout our land
such associations
our sincere citizens
like-minded as to the underlying
principles and ideals
would reach across the lines of creed or
of economic status
it would bring together
men and women
of all stations in life
to share their problems
to share their hopes
and to discover ways of mutual and
neighborly helpfulness
here perhaps is a way to pool
our spiritual resources
to find common ground
on which all of us of all faiths can
stand
and dance
to move forward
as men and women concerned for the
things of the spirit
[Applause]
i made the following declaration
in the field of world policy
i would dedicate this nation to the
policy of the good neighbor
the neighbor who resolutely respects
himself
and because he does so
respects the rights of others
the neighbor who respects his
obligations
and respects the sanctity of agreement
in and with
a world of neighbors
that declaration
represented my purpose then
it represents my purpose now
but it represents more than a purpose
now
for it stands for a practice
to a measurable degree
the practice has succeeded
the whole world now knows that the
united states cherishes
no predatory ambitions
[Applause]
we
we are strong
but less powerful nations know that they
need not fear our strength
we seek no conquest
we stand for peace
[Applause]
in the whole world of the western
hemisphere
our good neighbor policy has produced
results that are especially heartening
the noblest monument to peace
the noblest monument to economic and
social friendship in all the world
is not a monument in bronze or stone
it is the boundary that unites the
united states and canada
3 000 miles of friendship with no barbed
wires no guns no soldiers and no
passports on the whole frontier
[Applause]
what made it
mutual trust
and to extend the same sort of mutual
trust throughout the americas with our
aim
can be sustained only
by scrupulous respect
for the pledged word
[Applause]
and in spite of all this
we have sought steadfast steadfastly to
assist international movements to
prevent war
we cooperated to the bitter end
and it was a bitter end
in the work of the general disarmament
conference
when it failed we sought a separate
treaty
to deal with the manufacture of arms and
the international traffic in arms
that proposal also
came to north
we participated
again to the bitter end
in a conference to continue naval
limitations
and when it became evident that no
general treaty could be signed because
of the objections of certain other
nations
we concluded with great britain and
france
a conditional treaty
of qualitative limitations
which much to my regret already shows
signs of ineffectiveness
we shun political commitments
which might entangle us in foreign wars
we avoid connection with the political
activities
of the league of nations
but i am glad to say that we have
cooperated wholeheartedly
in the social and humanitarian work at
geneva
[Applause]
thus we are a part of the world effort
to control traffic and narcotics
to improve international health
to help child welfare to eliminate
double taxation and to better working
conditions and laboring hours throughout
the world
no we are not isolationists
except in so far as we seek to isolate
ourselves from war
[Applause]
yet we must remember
that so long as war exists on earth
there will be some danger
even to the nation
that most ardently desires peace
danger that it also
may be drawn into war
i have seen war
i have seen war
on land and sea
i have seen blood running from the
wounded
i have seen men coughing out their
gassed lungs
i have seen the dead
in the mud
i have seen cities destroyed
i have seen 200 limping exhausted men
come out of line
the survivors of a regiment of one
thousand that went forward 48 hours
before
i have seen children starving
i have seen the agony of mothers and
wives
i
hate
war
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes i have passed unnumbered hours
and i shall pass unnumbered hours
thinking and planning how war may be
kept
from the united states of america
i wish i could keep war from all nations
but that is beyond my power
i can at least make certain
that no act of the united states
helps to produce
or to promote war
i can at least make clear that the
conscience of america
revolts against war
and that any nation that provokes war
profits the sympathy of the people of
the united states
[Applause]
[Applause]
there are many causes that produce war
for ancient hatred
turbulent frontiers
the legacy of old forgotten far-off
things and battle
long ago
there are newborn fanaticism
convictions on the part of certain
peoples
that they have become the unique
depositories
of ultimate truth and right
clear that our present policy
and the measures passed by the congress
would in the event of a war on some
other continent
reduce
war profits
which would otherwise true
to american citizens
industrial and agricultural production
for a warm market
may give immense fortune
to a few
but for the nation as a whole
we know that it produces disaster
it was the prospect of war profits
that made our farmers in the west plough
prairie land that ought never to have
been plowed but should have been left
for grazing cattle
and today we're reaping the harvest of
those war prophets
in the dust storms that have devastated
those war plowed fields
it is the prospect of war profit
that caused the extension of monopoly
and unjustified expansion of industry
and a price level
so high that the normal relationship
between debtor and predator was
destroyed
nevertheless
if war should break out again in another
continent
let us not blink the fact
that we would find in this country
thousands of americans
who seeking immediate riches
full souls
would attempt to break down or evade
our neutrality
[Applause]
[Applause]
fortunately
their views would get wide publicity
by methods that you can understand as
readily as i do
that if they could produce and ship
this and that and the other article
to belligerent nations
the unemployed of america would all find
work
they would tell you that if they could
extend credit
to warring nations
that credit would be used in the united
states
to build homes and factories and pay our
debts
they would tell you that america once
more would capture the trade of the
world
my friends it would be hard to resist
that planner
it would be hard for many americans i
fear
to look beyond
to realize the inevitable penalties
the inevitable day of reckoning that
comes from a false prosperity
to resist the clamor of that greed if
war should come
would require the unswerving support of
all americans who love peace
and so
if we face the choice
the choice of profits or peace
this nation will answer
this nation must answer
we
choose peace
[Applause]
and it is the beauty of all of us each
and every one of us
men women and children
who encourage such a body of public
opinion throughout this nation that the
answer will be clear
and for all practical purposes unanimous
into the great war
in
1914 and eventually engulfed us and many
other nations
we can keep out of war
if those who watch and decide
have a sufficiently detailed
understanding of international affairs
to make certain that the small decisions
of each day
do not lead toward war
and if at the same time they possess the
courage to say no to those who selfishly
or unwisely
would get us into war
[Applause]
of all the nations in the world today
we are in many ways most singularly
blessed
our closest
neighbors are good neighbors
and if there are remoter nations
that wish us not good but ill
they know that we are strong
they know that we can and will
defend ourselves
and defend our neighborhood
they know that we seek to dominate no
other nation
that we ask no territorial expansion
that we oppose imperialism
and that we desire reduction in world
armament
we believe
in democracy
we believe
we believe in freedom
and we believe in peace
oh we offer
to every nation of the world
the hand clasp of the good neighbor
let those who wish our friendship
look us in the eye
and take our hands
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's live next saturday here on
american history tv
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
senators
and representatives
i have the distinguished honor
of presenting the president of the
united states
[Applause]
vice president
mr speaker
members of the senate of the house of
representatives
yesterday
december 7th
1941
a date which will live
in infamy
the united states of america
was suddenly and deliberately attacked
by naval and air forces of the empire of
japan
the united states was at peace
with that nation
and
at solicitation of japan
still in
conversation with its government
and its emperor
looking toward the maintenance of peace
in the pacific
indeed
one hour
after japanese air squadrons had
commenced bombing
in the american island of oahu
the japanese ambassador to the united
states
and his colleague
delivered
to our secretary of state
a formal reply
to a recent american message
and while this reply
stated that it seemed useless to
continue the existing diplomatic
negotiations
it contained no threat
or hint
of war
or of armed attacks
it will be recorded
that the distance of hawaii from japan
makes it obvious that the attack was
deliberately planned
many days or even weeks ago
during the intervening time
the japanese government
has deliberately sought to deceive the
united states
by false statements and expressions of
hope
for continued peace
the attack yesterday
on the hawaiian islands
has caused severe damage
to american naval and military forces
i regret to tell you that very many
american lives
have been lost
in addition american ships have been
reported torpedoed on the high seas
between san francisco and honolulu
yesterday
the japanese government also launched an
attack
against malaya
last night japanese forces attacked hong
kong
last night japanese forces attacked guam
last night japanese forces attacked
the philippine islands
last night the japanese
attacked wake island
and this morning the japanese attacked
midway island
japan has therefore undertaken a
surprise offensive
extending throughout the pacific area
the facts
of yesterday and today
speak for themselves
the people of the united states have
already
formed their opinions
and well understand the implications
for the very life
and safety of our nation
as commander-in-chief of the army and
navy
i have directed that all measures be
taken for our defense
but
always
will our whole nation
remember the character
of the onslaught against us
[Applause]
no matter how long it may take us
to overcome this premeditated invasion
the american people in their righteous
might
will win through
to absolute victory
[Applause]
i believe that i interpret
the will of the congress and of the
people
when i assert
that we will not only defend ourselves
to the uttermost
but will make it very certain
that this form of treachery shall never
again endanger us
[Applause]
hostilities
exist
there is no blinking at the fact
that our people
our territory
and our interests
are in grave danger
with confidence
in our armed forces
with the unbounding determination
of our
people we will gain
the inevitable triumph
so help us god
i ask
that the congress declare
that since
the unprovoked
and dastardly attack
by japan
on sunday
december 7
1941
a state of war
has existed
between the united states
and the japanese empire
congress with overwhelming acclaim then
voted the declaration of a state of war
and the president signed it three hours
after this historic scene
[Music]
to 7726
our american president's programming on
franklin d roosevelt continues
just ahead the president's first wartime
state of the union address delivered
january 6 1942
this footage is being shown courtesy of
the franklin d roosevelt library in hyde
park new york it runs about 40 minutes
on january 6 1942 president roosevelt
made his first wartime state of the
union address to an audience composed of
both houses of congress the supreme
court
the diplomatic car and packed galleries
the traditional presidential motorcade
up pennsylvania avenue to capitol hill
is shown
and a few moments later the president is
seen entering the chamber of the house
of representatives to address congress
and the nation
members of the congress
it's my high privilege to present to you
the president of the united states
vice president
mr speaker
members of the senate the house of
representatives of the united states
in fulfilling my
duty
to report upon the state of the union
i am proud to say to you
that the spirit of the american people
was never higher than it is today
the union was never more closely knit
together
and this country
was never more deeply determined
to face the solemn tasks before it
the response of the american people has
been instantaneous and it will be
sustained
until
our security is ashore
[Applause]
exactly one year ago today
i said to this congress
when the dictators are ready to make war
upon us they will not wait for an act of
war on our part
they not we
will choose the time and the place
and the method of their attack
we now know their choice of the time
a peaceful sunday morning
december 7th
1941
we know that choice of the place
an outpost an american outpost in the
pacific
we know their choice of the method
the method of hitler himself
japan's scheme of conquest goes back
half a century
it was not merely a policy of seeking
living room
it was a plan which included the
subjugation
of all the peoples in the far east and
in the islands of the pacific
and the domination of that ocean
by japanese military and naval control
of the western coasts
of north central and south america
the development of this ambitious
conspiracy
was marked
by the war against china
in 1894
the subsequent occupation of korea
the war against russia
in 1904
the illegal fortification of the
mandated pacific islands following 1920.
the seizure of manchuria in 1931
and the invasion of china in 1937.
a similar policy of criminal conquest
was adopted by italy
the fascists first revealed their
imperial designs in libya and tripoli
in 1935 they seized abyssinia
their goal
was the domination of all north africa
egypt
parts of france
and the entire mediterranean world
but the dreams of empire of the japanese
and fascist leaders
was modest
in comparison
with the gargantuan aspirations of
hitler and his nazis
even before they came to power
in
1933
their plans for that conquest had been
drawn
they provided for ultimate domination
not of any one section of the world
but of the whole earth
and all the oceans on it
when
hitler
organized his berlin rome tokyo alliance
all these plans of conquest became a
single plan
under this in addition to our own
schemes of conquest japan's role
was obviously to cut off
our supply of weapons of war
to britain and russia and china
weapons which increasingly were speeding
the day of hitler's doom
the act of japan at pearl harbor
was intended to stun us
to terrify us
to such an extent that we would divert
our industrial and military strength to
the pacific area
or even
to our own continental defense
the plan has failed in its purpose
we have not been stunned
we have not been terrified or confused
this very reassembling of the 77th
congress today
is proof of that
for the mood of quiet grim resolution
which here prevails
bodes ill
for those who conspired and collaborated
to murder world peace
and that mood is stronger
than any mere desire for revenge
it expresses the will of the american
people to make very certain
that the world
will never so suffer again
admittedly
we have been faced with hard choices
it was bitter for example not to be able
to relieve
the heroic and historic defenders of
wake island
it was bitter
for us not to be able to land
a million men
in a thousand ships
in the philippine islands
but this adds only to our determination
to seed to it that the stars and stripes
will fly again
over wake and guam
yes
see to it
that the brave people of the philippines
will be rid of japanese imperialism and
will live in freedom and security and
independence
powerful and offensive actions must and
will
be taken in proper time
the consolidation of the united nations
total war effort against our economy
enemies is being achieved
that
was and is
the purpose of conferences which have
been held during the past two weeks
in washington
and moscow
and chunking
that is the primary objective
of the declaration of solidarity signed
in washington on january 1st 1942
by 26 nations
against the axis power
difficult choices may have to be made in
the months to come
we do not shrink
from such decisions
we and those united with us will make
those decisions with courage and
determination
plans have been laid here and in the
other capitals
for coordinated and cooperative action
by all the united nations
military action and economic action
already we have established as you know
unified command of land sea and air
forces in the southwestern pacific
theater of war
there will be a continuation of
conferences and consultations among
military staffs
so that the plans and operations of each
will fit into the general strategy
designed to crush the enemy
we shall not fight isolated wars
each nation going its own way
these 26 nations are united not in
spirit and determination alone
but in the broad conduct of the war in
all its phases
for the first time since the japanese
and the fascists and the nazis started
along that blood-stained course of
conquest
they now face the fact
that superior authorities are assembling
against them
gone forever are the days when the
aggressors could attack and destroy
their victims one by one
destroy them without unity of resistance
we of the united nations will so dispose
our forces
that we can strike at the common enemy
wherever the greatest damage can be done
the militarists
of berlin and tokyo started this war
but the masked angered forces of common
humanity will finish it
destruction
destruction of the milk material and
spiritual centers of civilization
this has been
and still is the purpose of hitler and
is italian
and japanese chessmen
they would wreck the power of the
british commonwealth and of russia
and of china
and of the netherlands
and then combine all their forces to
achieve their ultimate goal
the conquest of the united states
they know that victory for us
means victory for freedom
they know that victory for us
means victory for the institution of
democracy
the ideal of the family the simple
principles of common decency and
humanity
they know that victory for us
means victory for religion
and they could not tolerate that
the world is too small
to provide adequate living room
for both hitler
and god
[Applause]
in proof of that
the nazis have now announced their plan
for enforcing
their new
german pagan religion all over the world
the plan by which the holy bible and the
cross of mercy
would be displaced
by mine camp
and the swastika and the naked sword
our own objectives are clear
the objective of smashing
the militarism imposed by warlords upon
their enslaved peoples
the objective of liberating the
subjugated nations
the objective of establishing and
securing
freedom of speech
freedom of religion
freedom from one
and freedom from fear
everywhere
in the world
we shall not stop short
of these objectives
nor shall we be satisfied merely to gain
them and then
call it a day
i know that i speak for the american
people
and i have good reason to believe that i
speak also for all the other peoples who
fight with us
when i say that this time
we are determined not only to win the
war but also
to maintain the security of the peace
that will follow
[Applause]
but we know that modern methods of
warfare make it a task
not only of shooting
and fighting
but an even more urgent one
of working and producing
victory requires the actual weapons of
war
and the means of transporting them to a
dozen points of combat
it will not be sufficient for us and the
other united nations to produce a
slightly superior supply of munitions
to that of germany and japan and italy
and the stolen industries in the
countries which they have overrun
the superiority of the united nations in
munitions and ships
must be overwhelming
so overwhelming the axis nations can
never hope to catch up with it
and so in order to attain this
overwhelming superiority
the united states must build planes and
tanks and guns and ships
to the utmost limit of our national
capacity
we have
the ability and capacity to produce arms
not only for our own forces but also
for the armies navies and air forces
fighting on our side
and
our overwhelming superiority of armament
must be adequate to put weapons of war
at the proper time
into the hands of those men in the
conquered nations
who stand ready to seize the first
opportunity to revolt
against their german and japanese
oppressors and against against the
traitors in their own ranks
known by the already infamous name of
whistling
and i think
that it is a fair prophecy
to say that as we get guns to the
patriots in those lands
they too
will fire shots heard around the world
this production of ours in the united
states must be raised far above present
levels
even though it will mean the dislocation
of the lives and occupations of millions
of our own people
we must raise our sights all along the
production line
let no man say it cannot be done
it must be done and we have undertaken
to do it
i have just sent
a letter of directive
to the appropriate departments and
agencies of our government
ordering that immediate steps be taken
first to increase our production rate of
airplanes
so rapidly that in this year 1942
we shall produce sixty thousand planes
ten thousand
ten thousand by the way more than the
goal that we set a year and a half ago
this includes 45 000 combat planes
bombers dive bombers pursuit planes
the rate of increase
will be maintained
continued
so that next year 1943
we shall produce a
125 000 airplanes including
a hundred thousand combat planes
[Applause]
second
to increase our production rate of tanks
so rapidly that in this year 1942
we shall produce 45 000 tanks
and to continue that increase so that
next year 1943
we shall produce 75 000 tanks
third
to increase our production rate of
anti-aircraft guns
so rapidly that in this year 1942 we
shall produce
20 000 of them
and to continue that increase so that
next year
1943 we shall produce 35 000
anti-aircraft guns
and fought
to increase our production rate of
merchant ships
so rapidly that in this year 1942 we
shall build
8
million dead weight tons
as compared with a 1941
completed production
of one million one hundred thousand
[Applause]
and finally we shall continue that
increase
so that next year 1943
we shall build 10 million tons of
shipping
these figures
and similar figures for a multitude of
other implements of war
will give
the japanese and the nazis
a little idea
of just what they accomplished in the
attack at pearl harbor
and i rather hope
that all these figures which i have
given
will become common knowledge
in germany and japan
our task is hard
our task is unprecedented and the time
is short
we must train every existing
armament-producing facility to the
utmost
we must convert every available plant
and fuel to war production
that goes all the way from the greatest
plants to the smallest
from the huge automobile industry to the
village machine shop
production for war is based on men and
women
the human hands and brains which
collectively we call labor
our workers stand ready to work long
hours
to turn out more in a day's work
to keep the wheels turning and the fires
burning
24 hours a day and seven days a
week they realize well that on the speed
and efficiency of their work
depend the lives of their sons and their
brothers on the fighting front
production for war is based on metals
and raw materials
steel copper rubber
aluminum zinc
tin
greater and greater quantities of them
will have to be diverted to war purposes
civilian use of them will have to be cut
further and still further
and in many cases completely eliminated
war costs money
so far we've hardly even begun
to pay for it
we've devoted only 15 of our national
income to national defense
as will appear
in my budget message tomorrow
our war program for the coming fiscal
year
will cost
56
billion
or in other words
more than half of the estimated annual
national income
that means
taxes
and bonds
and bonds and taxes
it means cutting luxuries and other
non-essential
a word it means an all-out war
by individual effort
and family effort in a united country
only this all-out scale of production
will hasten the ultimate all out victory
speed will come
lost ground
can always be regained
lost time
never
speed will save lives
speed will save this nation which is in
peril
speed
will save our freedom and our
civilization
and slowness
well it has never been
an american characteristic
as the united states goes into its full
stride
we must always be on guard
on god against
misconceptions
which will arise some of them naturally
or which will be planted among us by our
enemies
we must guide against complacency we
must not underrate the enemy
he is powerful and cunning
and cruel
and ruthless
he will stop at nothing
that gives him a chance to kill
and to destroy
he has trained his people
to believe that their highest protection
is achieved by waging war
for many years he is prepared for this
very conflict planning and plotting
and training
arming and fighting
we have already tasted defeat
we may suffer further
we must face the fact of a hard war
a long war
a bloody war
a costly war
we must on the other hand
guard against defeatism
that
has been one of the chief weapons of
hitler's propaganda machine
used time
and again with deadly results
it will not be used successfully on the
american people
we must guard against divisions among
ourselves and among all the other united
nations
we must be particularly vigilant against
racial discrimination in any of its ugly
forms
hitler will try again to breed mistrust
and suspicion
between one individual and another one
group one another one race and another
one government and another
he will try to use the same technique of
falsehood and rumor mongering
with which he divided france from
britain
he is trying to do this even now
but he will find a unity
a unity of will and purpose against him
which will persevere
until the destruction of all his black
designs upon the freedom and people of
the world are ended
we cannot wage this war and the
defensive spirit
as our power and our resources are fully
mobilized
we shall carry the attack
against the enemy
we shall hit him
and hit him again
wherever and whenever we can reach him
we must keep him far from our shores for
we intend to bring this battle to him
on his own home grounds
[Applause]
american armed forces
must be used at any place in all the
world
where it seems advisable to engage the
forces of the enemy
in some cases these operations will be
defensive in order to protect key
positions
in other cases these operations will be
offensive
in order to strike at the common enemy
with a view to his complete encirclement
and eventual total
defeat american armed forces will
operate
at many points
in the far east
american armed forces will be on all the
oceans
helping to guard the essential
communications which are vital to the
united nations
american land and air and sea forces
will take stations in the british isles
which constitute an essential portrait
in this great world struggle
[Applause]
american armed forces will help to
protect this hemisphere
and help also to protect bases outside
this hemisphere
which could be used for an attack on the
america
if any of our enemies from europe or
from asia
attempt long-range wage
by suicide squadrons of bombing planes
they will do so only in the hope of
terrorizing our people and disrupting
our morale
people are not afraid of that
we know that we may have to pay a heavy
price
for freedom
we will pay this price
with a will whatever the price
[Applause]
it is a thousand times worth
no matter what our enemies
in their desperation may attempt to do
to us
we will say as the people of london have
said we can take it and what's more
what's more
we can give it back
and we will give it back with compound
interest
[Applause]
when our enemies challenged our country
to stand up and fight
they challenge each and every one of us
and each and every one of us
has accepted the challenge
for himself
and for his nation
there are only some
there were only some 400 united states
marines
who in the heroic and historic defense
of wake island
inflicted such great losses on the enemy
some of those men were killed in action
and others are now prisoners of war
when the survivors of that great fight
are liberated and restored to their
homes
they will learn that
130 million of their fellow citizens
have been inspired
to render their own full share
of service and sacrifice
we can well say that our men
on the fighting fronts have already
proved
that americans today are just as rugged
and just as tough as any of the heroes
whose exploits we celebrate on the 4th
of july
[Applause]
many people ask
when will this war end
there's only one answer to that
it will end just as soon as we make it
end
by our combined efforts our combined
strength
our combined determination to fight
through and work through until the end
the end
of militarism
in germany
and italy and japan
[Applause]
most certainly
we shall not settle for less
that is the spirit in which discussions
have been conducted during the visit
of the british prime minister to
washington
churchill and i
understand each other
our motives
and our purposes
together during the past two weeks we
have faced squarely the major military
and economic problems
of this greatest world war
all in our nation
have been cheered
by mr churchill's visit
we have been deeply stirred
by his great message to us
he is welcome in our midst
now
and in days to come
and we unite in wishing him
a safe return
to his home
[Applause]
for we are fighting on the same side
with the british people who fought alone
for long terrible months
and withstood the enemy with fortitude
and tenacity and skill
we are fighting on the same side with
the russian people
who have seen the nazi horde swarm up to
the very gates of moscow
and who with almost superhuman will
and courage
have forced the invaders back into
retreat
[Applause]
we are fighting on the same side as the
brave people of china
those millions who were four and a half
long years
have withstood bombs and starvation
and equipped the invaders time and again
in spite of the superior japanese
equipment and arms
yes we are fighting
on the same side
as the indomitable dutch
we are fighting on the same side
as all the other governments in exile
whom hitler and all his armies
and all his gestapo have not been able
to conquer
but we
of the united nations
are not making all this sacrifice of
human effort and human lives
to return to the kind of world
we had after the last world war
we are fighting today for security
for progress
and for peace
not only for ourselves but for all men
not only for one generation but for all
generations
we are fighting to cleanse the world of
ancient evils
ancient ills
our enemies are guided
by brutal cynicism
by unholy contempt
for the human race
we
are inspired by a faith
that goes back through all the years to
the first chapter of the book of genesis
god created man
in his own image
we on our side are striving to be cruel
to that divine heritage
we are fighting as our fathers are
thought
to uphold the doctrine that all men are
equal
in the sight of god
those on the other side
are striving to destroy
this deep belief
and to create a world
in their own image
a world of tyranny
and cruelty
and certain
that is the conflict the day and night
now pervades our lives
no compromise can end that conflict
the never has been the never can be
successful compromise between good and
evil
only
only total victory
can reward
the champions of tolerance
and decency
and freedom
and faith
[Applause]
now more on franklin d roosevelt with a
look at the little white house in warm
springs georgia where roosevelt spent
much of his time away from the white
house it lasts just under 25 minutes
[Music]
the russian army will continue its stern
offensives
on germany's eastern front
the allied armies in africa and italy
will bring relentless pressure
on germany from the south
and now the encirclement will be
complete
as great american and british forces
attack
from other points of the compass
the commander selected to lead the
combined attack from these other points
is general dwight d eisenhower
his performances in africa sicily and
italy have been brilliant
he knows by practical and successful
experience
the way to coordinate air sea and land
power
the united nations have no intention
to enslave the german people
we wish them to have a normal chance to
develop
to develop in peace
as useful and respectable members of the
european family
but we most certainly emphasize that
word respectable
well we intend to rid them
once and for all
of nazism and oppression militarism
and the fantastic and disastrous notion
that they constitute
the master race
the war is now reaching the stage
where we shall have to look forward to
large casualty lists
dead wounded and missing
war entails just that
there is no easy road to victory
and the end is not yet in sight
here's a preview president roosevelt's
inauguration in 1945
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
at the white house in washington crowds
gather for the inauguration of franklin
d roosevelt as president of the united
states for a fourth term
invitations admit 7 000 guests to the
white house ground
[Music]
among the guests are wounded servicemen
from nearby military hospitals
[Music]
before the south portico of the white
house the crowd lines up for the first
time an inauguration is held not at the
capitol building but here in the
president's own backyard
[Music]
from the portico steps 13 grandchildren
of the president watch the ceremony at
the bottom of the steps is harry hopkins
presidential advisor and aide
government leaders arrived for the
ceremonies secretary of war and mrs
stimson
secretary of navy and mrs forrestall
secretary of the interior harold ickes
harlan fisk stone chief justice of the
united states
admiral of the fleet ernest king
edward arcedinius secretary of state and
mrs cetinius
general of the army's george c marshall
and mrs marshall
now in a grim year of war the shortest
and simplest inaugural on record begins
former vice president wallace swears in
harry truman new vice president
president roosevelt takes the oath of
office
i franklin delano roosevelt
who solemnly swear
that i will faithfully execute the
office of president of the united states
and will to the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states so
help you god go help me god
the president delivers a brief inaugural
address
we americans of today
together with our allies
are passing through a period of supreme
test
it is a test of our courage
of our resolve
of our wisdom
of our essential democracy
if we meet that test
successfully and honorably
we shall perform a service
of historic importance
of historic importance which men and
women and children
will honor throughout all time
as i stand here today
having taken the solemn oath of office
in the presence of my fellow countrymen
in the presence of our god
i know that it is america's purpose that
we shall not fail
in the days and the years
that are come
we shall work for a just and honorable
peace
a bearable peace
as today we work and fight
for total victory in war
[Music]
saturday january 19th live at 11am
eastern the history
[Music]
on april 12 1945 president franklin
roosevelt died from a stroke while
visiting warm springs georgia he was 63.
next a 16-minute biographical
documentary showing parts of the funeral
then scenes from president roosevelt's
life and political career
produced by official films this program
is part of the prelinger archives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
on the afternoon of april 12 1945
the lowering of the white house flag
confirmed the passing of america's 31st
president and from warm springs georgia
the mortal remains of franklin delano
roosevelt began the long trip home
[Music]
slowly the long black funeral train
rolled up from the south
then down pennsylvania avenue to the
beat of muffled drums
the president was born for the last time
to the executive mansion
that for 12 years had been his official
home
the passing of fdr from the american
scene came as a personal shock to the
nation
people wept openly
unashamed of their grief
[Music]
drawn by six white horses the flag
draped caisson was brought to the main
entrance of the white house
carried into the great east room where
80 years before almost to the day
the body of abraham lincoln also had
laid in state
at hyde park his ancestral home in
dutchess county new york the guns of
west point cadets rang down the final
curtain on the man of destiny known
round the world as fdr
to measure something of his greatness we
turn back the clock to franklin
roosevelt as a young man making his
first political campaign
to the time when only 28 years of age he
was elected new york state senator and
broke the powerful republican machine
that had ruled duchess county for 28
years
emerging as a national figure he served
president wilson as assistant secretary
of navy
in 1920 as running mate of ohio's james
m cox
fdr at the age of 38 was the youngest
vice presidential candidate in history
married on st patrick's day 1905 to anna
eleanor roosevelt niece of the
illustrious teddy
fdr founded the goal of his hudson river
dutch
it was to the roosevelt retreat the
vacation cottage on campobello island
that fdr sailed with his friends and
family after the strenuous campaign for
the vice presidency
and it was in these same waters that
they have funded that he was first
stricken with a dread polio germ that
was to paralyze his legs but never his
life
[Music]
called in 1928 to the state capitol in
albany franklin roosevelt was elected
governor of new york
with al smith his old friend the happy
warrior at his side he threw himself
into the fight for better government
became the champion of the common man
was widely of his next democrat for the
presidency of the united states
[Music]
and with big genial james a farley
swinging the gavel the die was cast a
country still mired in the morass of
depression wanted a new president
[Music]
call to chicago to accept the nomination
governor roosevelt's wife son eliot and
son john
you knew it then but this was the
beginning of an era unparalleled in
american history
[Music]
fdr's appearance in chicago stadium was
the beginning of a series of spectacular
personal triumphs
swept into office by the greatest
landslide in history his first words
were fearless prophetic
i am prepared
under my constitutional duty
to recommend the measures that a
stricken nation in the midst of a
stricken world may require
these measures
or such other measures
as the congress may build
out of its experience
and wisdom
i shall seek within my constitutional
authority to bring to speedy adoption
but
in the event that the congress shall
fail to take one of these two causes
in the event that the national emergency
is still critical
i shall not evade the clear course of
duty
that will then confront me
i shall ask the congress for the one
remaining instrument to meet the crisis
fraud
executive power
to wage a war against the emergency
as great
as the power that would be given to me
if we were in fact invaded by a fire and
fall
fdr's first term was marked by an
ominous period of world unrest
men of many nations were again taking up
arms
our own national defense was at its
lowest ever
america new flood and famine drought and
the dust bowl
fdr brought farm relief and flood
control
[Music]
water power and giant public works
social security was born old age
insurance became a new responsibility of
government
the price of gold was fixed the american
dollar became the soundest in the world
the forgotten man was remembered the
country held its leader as a pathfinder
the initials fdr began to stand for
progress for national security
[Music]
the fireside chat became an american
institution
with steve early martin mcintyre the
white house secretarial staff helped in
the preparation of his radio reports to
the nation
the president's talks were masterpieces
of simplicity and directness
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
my friends
the american public and with that now
familiar salutation he brought his
messages straight to the firesides of
the people
he talked with them in their homes about
the vital issues of the day
roosevelt never gave up hope in his
battle against infantile paralysis
in the healing waters of warm springs in
the white house pool
swimming was his one relaxation his only
exercise
how he organized the great warm springs
foundation for the eventual benefit of
the nation's half million polio victims
will forever stand as a living monument
to his name
and each year on his birthday
all over the land little children sing
his praise
happy birthday
[Music]
this intimate study of the president and
his beloved father is one of the rare
personal portraits in a busy crowded
life
for no man in our time nor in any time
perhaps
has been called on to make the momentous
decisions that have been his
his one goal his greatest ambition was
to lead the nations of the world into a
lasting peace
[Music]
royalty from many nations the king and
queen of england have been guests in his
home
with the world's most powerful rulers he
commanded supreme respect with a keen
grasp of international affairs he
foresaw by many years the trend of the
world's march
1936 speaking at chautauqua new york he
gave the nation words that have been
quoted again and again
i've always thought that peace
like charity begins at home
[Applause]
and that's why
we have begun at home
here
in north and south and central america
but peace in the western world is not
all we seek
i have seen war
i have seen war
on land and sea
i have seen blood running from the
wounded
i have seen children starving
i have seen the agony of mothers and
wives
i
hate war
1940 found the nation facing war
voters took the third term issue
squarely to the polls
with the magic power of fdr shatter all
president
the voice of the people was heard
the results are now conclusive roosevelt
wins
the nation was jubilant fdr had done it
again
and at hyde park square roosevelt and
his family received the well wishes of
their neighbors
again the president addressed the nation
in the presence of cabinet members of
diplomats and leaders from nations south
of the border
fdr asked for broader powers than had
ever before been given to any american
president
the first and fundamental fact is that
what started as a european war
has developed as the nazis always
intended it should develop
into a war for world domination
therefore with profound consciousness of
my responsibilities to my countrymen
and to my country's cause
i have tonight issued a proclamation
that an unlimited national emergency
exists
and requires the strengthening of our
defense
to the extreme limit
of our national power and authority
with the world facing the greatest
conflict of all time with the rights of
all free people endangered roosevelt met
winston churchill on the high seas
gave a pledge to the world
pledged the right of all people to
choose their own form of government
history records this dramatic meeting as
the birth of the atlantic charter
[Music]
december 7 1941 a day of infamy that was
burned into the pages of american
history
[Music]
the president face the nation united
i ask
that the congress declare
that since
the unprovoked
and dastardly attack
by japan
on sunday
december 7
1941
a state of war
has existed
between the united states and the
japanese empire
[Music]
in 1942 fdr startled the world by
meeting churchill de gaulle and jerome
in casablanca
gave the axis two words
unconditional surrender
[Music]
at quebec roosevelt with churchill
planned the invasion of europe and with
the future of civilization and the
balance the role these two played in
this most critical period is indelibly
written in history
at cairo for conferences with chiang
kai-shek fdr wrote a new chapter in
international relations
gave assurance to the people of china of
unstinted allied aid in their war
against japan
was the guiding hand in bringing
together the many conflicting forces of
east and west
[Applause]
[Music]
such was the man who met stalin for the
first time at tehran
who gave the world its first promise of
complete accord between the three great
powers
but these were called the big three was
no empty phrase
and franklin roosevelt steadfast in his
convictions was the biggest of them all
steaming into pearl harbor for the first
time since the outbreak of war the
commander in chief conferred with
admiral nimitz and general macarthur
that he took an active part in planning
the war in the pacific is now apparent
for it is known that from this
conference emerged the blueprint for
liberation of the philippines
[Music]
fdr began his fourth term in office firm
in his belief that men are capable of
their own government
but no king no tyrant no dictator can
govern them as wisely as they can govern
themselves and upon that note he placed
the world's future on the conference
table at yalta
made plans to bring together the nations
and the peoples of the world in a just
and lasting peace
history has recorded that first step as
the san francisco conference
[Music]
in this his last report to congress and
the american people is to be found the
text of his life
in the last words of a man grown tired
in public service
is a heritage for all men
everywhere
i'm confident
congress and the american people
to accept the results of this conference
at the beginning
our permanent structure of peace
upon which we can begin to build
under god
that better world
in which our children and grandchildren
yours
and mine
the children and grandchildren of the
whole world
must live
and scan live
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
join american history tv this coming
you